hey madeline hey ross hello
hey nice to meet you too so i love this
film obviously i love the first two
films too but this one's extra special
how do you think the fans are gonna
react the ending of this
film to how everybody wraps things up
madeline how about you
i feel like it's the perfect bow to this
kind of epic
saiga and i personally
love it and obviously i'm biased and i
hope that the fans enjoy it as much as
we enjoyed making it
and uh enjoy it as much as as we do when
we watch it i feel like it really
uh you see the evolution of all the
characters and
see them as they go off onto their
different journeys
i love that uh ross what is it meant for
you to be a part of the
to all the boys worlds uh it's just been
honestly really fun that's all i've been
able to say about it because that's all
it really has
it's just been a fun ride to be brought
into this family and just uh
to be like the weird step brother just
being like hey i'm here now
i'm weird hope you guys can be weird
with me um
yeah it's just been really fun and just
to make these friends that you know i'll
have for the rest of my life is just
sounds cheesy but it's great always in
forever
oh i love that you're good oh you're
this isn't your first interview um
how much do you guys how much you guys
missed each other like do you already
miss each other
so much i wish i could hug everyone
right now yeah
yeah unfortunately we can't blame
i i live by noah so noah and i have been
we've been hanging out but i wish i
could
go for for dinners and movie nights with
with everybody else but i don't think
they're
no they're not in l.a so um everyone's
kind of scattered too
but we luckily have technology like zoom
and
uh i've kept in contact with lana and
and
also most of the cast so we've uh we're
lucky that we can connect that way
i love it well with this film coming
right before valentine's day do you guys
have any plans for love in lockdown
ross how about you not really like i'm
kind of
kind of single that's okay
no no i mean it's fine no i i don't i
don't know like
valentine's day for me is always kind of
it's like a
like i don't need one day to express my
love for somebody i prefer the small
things every day rather than a big lump
of
roses on one day you know
yeah but the chocolate is nice madeleine
how about you
i'm gonna say the chocolate is nice i'm
with ross that we should
share and express our love every day but
i love that we take one day to celebrate
it a little more and we eat a little
more chocolate
and i love chocolate so i'm not gonna
complain if i eat more chocolate that
day yeah
i love it um ross how excited are you
to reena with the cast of shazam for the
sequel
oh wow yeah no i'm super pumped like um
we've been just kind of waiting to see
when we can shoot this
the sequel so now i'm ready to to get
back i went to austin to go visit zach
and we just reconnected and
yeah i can't wait to see everyone and
suit back up
yeah that's so exciting well thanks so
much guys congrats on this film and it
was really nice chatting with you
yeah lovely to meet you
you